so the now disgraced and criminally
charged crypto exchange FTX has just
sent out letters to politicians who they
sent money to saying hey can you return
the money we sent you because a million
people got defrauded maybe they should
have some of the money it's not clear if
that's ever going to happen it's also
not clear if any of the many media
Outlets that took ill-gotten gains from
FDX like the left-wing blog semaphore
will ever pay that money back now this
is the biggest Financial Scandal
probably in history
Joe Biden is expected to ignore it
completely tonight even though the
Democratic party was the main political
beneficiary of the money from FTX Glenn
Greenwald is a journalist working on sub
stack finds the story interesting he
joins us tonight Glenn thanks so much
for coming up it it's a little weird
like the cynical among us when the FTX
story broke said to one another this
will be out of the news in a week and
actually it was does that shock you
yes and no I mean it would be like you
know if Bernie Madoff was found to be
with his tentacles and a bunch of
political offices you would think that
would be a story that would go on for a
long time I think the reason why they
wanted to get rid of this is It's too
revealing you know I remember the time
that Trump boasted the fact that he
could before being president could
anyone on the phone in Washington by
just offering them up a check and they
would do whatever he asked for that of
course is how DC works and this shows it
there are politicians who are very
liberal who usually would be in favor of
regulating a new currency a
cryptocurrency who suddenly got adamant
that the government should stay out of
it it turns out they were getting big
money from FTX there are you know he
said in an interview Sam makemanfree did
that he purposely touted his donations
to Democrats and hid the ones he made to
Republicans because the only way to be
popular among the media is by having
them think that you're donating to
Democrats if they donate to Republicans
they hate you so there's so much going
on here that reveals a little bit to too
bright of a light on how Washington
really works
and I wonder if is there any hope you
spent so many years in the media that
somebody well-funded news organization
will just get to the bottom of it right
a clear series on what happened ever
the problem is is that he was buying out
media Outlets as well I mean so many of
them were recipients of huge amounts of
money The Intercept where I used to work
I founded it uh and then quit got huge
Grant from him and to this day refuses
to return it and everyone knows
including these politicians it's not
their money that money was stolen it was
a Ponzi scheme and people are out
without their money while these media
outlets and politicians keep the money
that doesn't belong to them
it's it's really unbelievable Glenn
Greenwald thank you for that perspective
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else